so new round
opponent is edgar from the usa
1940 i'm just before the and
2009 kalashnikov variant c c4 good
game that anyway only after
free snout because i do
n't know
about let's think that that would have to pay
to exchange the rotor here  if we
allow it so easily
no one can maybe not
well away
with the queen
yes well not sure where the knight
belongs in which he here
maybe we can go over the 7c 56 to thief
4 dirt goes in there
now I could  course runner
simple 5 last here after
bringing the five and at least prevent him from
forever planting a piece may make
you notice that so you don't know exactly
very often jumper b8 is also a new
idea because he can come over the 745
here and there one I know  not whether
springer here seven is better here and
bringing wings to
koniz I was therefore given the four against three
majority
yes yes yes white should probably
j  now two plans he can
try to play as fast as four somehow
or he can try to play on the
kingside with f4 or something like that
so knight the seven that knight it
looks a bit uncomfortable g6 weaken a bit
because sometimes he jump five
but you can't tolerate it either  if he
shows up
in the direction of 25 but it will
probably be more doesn't make b4 good
so
now maybe davis damme b 6n the
idea of operating with the bondage it says a bit
stupid in there now if he
does
now plays rock tage.de 404 surfe
simply the fourth makes that something doesn't
go away somehow
yes he prevented this direct way
so
yes I could now could take monkeys
then he jumps five also hangs the 3
well they are therefore not interested
try it out if we now have
springer ag fourth roth like that  he
serves
I could also take b2 or is
that too greedy now
? It depends on f6 dhabi 2.1 and then the 6 hangs
I have to
in any case, I was incredibly
slow
so I have to prevent my move like
this if you joke about the brg 4 or
erich and that's how you're
right  f3 i have now jump
f2 well then right well
i'll say it or give up right away
can try a bit over the
little time but okay the problem is
also a bit not only the source
is gone but the figures are
all chained together so weird so
i have  after that maybe carries
four or in the f3 as a
threat yes everything somehow depends yes
well a little faster I should
maybe played despite